Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar.
A convex quadrilateral is divided into four parts by its diagonals
Three of the areas are two, one, and three as shown in the diagram
What is the area of the fourth region denoted by x?
I want to thank Gerrit for sending me this problem and a solution
Can you figure it out? Give this problem a try, and when you're ready, keep watching the video for a solution
Rather than solving this specific problem,
I will solve a more general problem in which the four areas are s1, s2, s3, and s4
I'll label the vertices of the quadrilateral as A, B, C and D,
and I'll mark the point at which the diagonals meet as E
In order to write formulas for each of these areas,
we will draw altitudes from vertices A and C to diagonal BD
From vertex A, for example, we'll draw an altitude which has a height of h1
From vertex C, we'll draw another altitude which has a height of h2
We can now use the formula for the area of a triangle to figure out the areas of each of these regions
For example,
s1 is the area of a triangle, which has a base of DE and a height of h1
So s1 will equal DE times h1, divided by 2
Similarly, s2 is the area of a triangle which has a base of BE and a height of h1
so s2 equals BE times h1 divided by 2
We can, continue writing the formulas for the areas of these regions using the same principle
Now if you look at these formulas and perhaps rearrange these equations, you'll notice something familiar in these variables
The variables in the first two sets of equations are exactly the same variables in the next two sets of equations
In fact, if you multiply the first two equations, you would get exactly the same result as if you multiplied the third and fourth equations
So we end up with the principle that s1 times s3 equals s2 times s4
We can now take this formula and use the specific numbers from our original problem to solve for x
We substitute in our values and we end up with x is equal to 6
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video please subscribe to my channel I make videos on math
You can catch me on my blog
Mind Your Decisions
If you like this video, you can support me on patreon or you could check out my books
Which are listed in the video description
You can also catch me on social media, either at Mind Your Decisions or at preshtalwalkar